donner un jour de congé ou de rtt au
bénéfice du personnel soignant
après deux mois confrontées à l'épidémie
à applaudir à 20 heures beaucoup de
français se disent prêts à franchir le
pas on vient de passer un moment très
difficile
je pense que c'est tout à fait normal
ouais tout à fait normal que qu'on aide
les gens qu'il faut c'est le premier à
donner mes jours de repos
moi oui je serai prête à leur accorder
pour qu'ils reparlent du temps avec leur
famille un élan de solidarité qui touche
les premiers concernés même si les
attendent d'abord des réponses sur la
prise des congés ou le paiement des
heures supplémentaires
c'est vrai qu'on ait épuisé on est
fatigué on se demande même si on va
pouvoir prendre nos jours de repos déjà
qu'on a donc qu'on nous doit on est en
train de demander donc encore aux autres
français de se sacrifier quoi
d'un côté et bah c'est vrai que c'est
une valorisation pour le métier enfin
pour les professionnels de santé mais ça
vient toujours pas de l'état en fait
pour la cfdt c'est surtout un faux débat
qui ne s'attaque pas aux problèmes de
fond les salaires et les conditions de
travail
c'est là l'état employeur de prendre ses
responsabilités de répondre aux
questions de rémunération de protection
des personnels
ce n'est pas seulement aux salariés de
prendre en charge cette question de la
solidarité
rémy rebeyrotte fait partie des trois
députés bourguignons qui ont signé le
courrier à la ministre du travail pour
lui il ne s'agit pas pour l'état de se
défausser
nous sommes une solidarité des citoyens
vis-à-vis des soignants est aussi une
autre porte ouverte
faut pas tout attendre non plus de 2 les
tailles du gouvernement il peut y avoir
aussi et initiatives qui sont d'une
autre nature
les jeunes n'empêchera pas les autres la
proposition a été évoquée mardi à
l'assemblée est jugée très intéressante
par muriel pénicaud
elle devrait être discutée dans les
prochaines semaines avant d'être
éventuellement soumis au vote